there were cheers and there were tears
and dismay but in the end the EU Canada
trade deal Sita was signed the
comprehensive economic and trade
agreement eliminates almost all import
duties between Canada and the EU the EU
is set again from eleven point six
billion euros worth of income a year and
Canada eight point two billion euros the
deal gives the EU the green light to bid
for Canadian public contract while
making more affordable products
available in canada in exchange canada
gets almost unlimited access to the
large EU market where it can sell its
products at a competitive advantage sita
also ensures both sides recognized
university diplomas and are allowed to
protect specialty food like olives local
cheeses and hams labour standards are
not affected the deal also protect
public services as well as certain foods
like milk or poultry supporters of the
agreement claim exporters will save up
to 500 million euros a year the european
parliament's trade committee voted for
the deal now it's up to the cleaner e to
ratify it then national parliaments get
their say but critics say the EU hasn't
learned from brag that branding Sita a
bounty for extremist parties across
Europe even if Caesar goes through other
transatlantic treaties are in doubt US
President Donald Trump has promised to
reject trade agreements that don't favor
American industries
you